How do I pronounce the star? Well, that's a good question.
So I run a Twitter poll and the answer is nobody seems to know.
What do you say when you were at an astronomy conference and someone says,
so professor Merrifield,
what do you think about the latest happenings on [inaudible]?
Uh, I, I don't go to that kind of conference cause I don't do stars.
It's difficult because it's a corruption of an Arabic name.
So actually quite how you're supposed to pronounce a corrupted Arabic name.
I'm not sure. Um, so you can really pronounce it, how you like,
but let's go with beetle traditionally.
It's a star it's relatively massive star. About 10 times the mass of the sun.
It's if you look at the constellation of Orion,
which is one of the few that most people recognize,
it's the star at the top left of, of Orion.
And the reason why everyone's excited about it is because it's fading at the
moment quite dramatically.
And the other interesting fact about it is that in astronomical terms,
it's likely to blow up sometime in the near future.
And people have kind of put these two facts together and equated the fact that
it's fading at the moment as a sign that is about to go.
Wow, is it about to go?
I think it's unlikely. So I was a bit careful in what I said,
and I said in astronomical terms, it's going to go pretty soon.
And that just basically means it's probably going to blow up sometime in the
next hundred and 50,000 years.
So the chances of it being tomorrow are pretty slim,
I would say is actually well documented as a variable star.
It has its some sort of quasi periodic things or some longish timescale
variation. There's a shortage timescale variation.
So there's lots of variability going in on it. It is a complete mess.
And so actually, although this is the faintest it's been in recent times,
it's not really unprecedented for it to be fading.
If, and when it does blow up,
will that be proceeded by a sudden and dramatic fade?
Nobody knows because no one's ever seen one of these things that close up and
seen it before it blew up to know what it's going to do.
So no one really quite knows. And the reason,
part of the reason why no one knows is because it really is a very messy system.
It's big extended bloated kind of thing.
There's all sorts of processes going on in it.
So quite what the sequence of events would be that you'd actually see from the
outside is really something of a mystery at this point.
Oh,
I thought we modeled stars all the time and we've got all these theories about
what the explosion looks like and how it's soap soaping over works and like a
will supernova, presumably.
We are supernova and yet you're right. You know,
we sort of have a broad brush understanding and the sort of the physics that's
going on, but it's like, you know,
it's like the difference between climate and weather, right?
That actually even if you think, you know, what's going on in the climate,
you don't know what tomorrow is,
whether it's going to be like a really what's going on in the outer layers is
very much the weather and the, the,
the climate is the explosion that's going to occur right.
In the core of it and how these two things are coupled together is really quite
complicated. So we really don't know what you'd expect to see in the days,
months, years leading up to the explosion.
Because before this Beetlejuice stuff, if you'd asked me Brady,
what do you think happens to a star in the year or two or the week or two before
it blows up? I would have said, Oh, I bet it gets really, really bright.
And if you'd asked me the same question, I'd probably have said the same thing.
You'd think that that would be the, what would be going on. But as I say,
it really is because what's going on right in the middle,
where there were probably also pretty frantic nuclear processes going on, right.
In those low dying days of the star.
And what you actually see in the outer parts are really only very loosely
coupled together.
So really isn't that clear what you'd end up seeing in those last few weeks.
But you think like if you're a betting, man.
I'd be prepared to put a fair amount of money on it, not going in my lifetime,
which would be a shame because I'd love to see it. But, uh, no, probably not.
If we do a bit of a job of an astronomy for a while, actually,
because when it does go,
it's going to be brighter than the moon or about as bright as the moon.
And so the kind of astronomy I do, I tend to do away from full moon. Um,
and this going to be like having another bright light up there,
this is almost as bright as the full moon. So for a year or so,
the kind of astronomy I like doing is going to be quite hard to do because
there'll be this new, bright light in the sky.
Or Avon muscular, the ruined sky by then, it's true.
Um, you know, for the dramatic,
for the drama of getting to see a stall blowing up,
I'm prepared to put up with not doing my kind of astronomy for a year. I think.
You said you'd be willing to put money on it not being in your lifetime. Yup.
That should run markets on astronomy events. I don't really ever do that.
Do they?
I've never like you can bet on everything aren't you can bet on who's going to
be the next prime minister and who's going to be that they should have bets on
astronomical event.
I bet you could, you know, if you wanted to,
I'm sure your local bookie would be able to figure out some words for you.
If you wanted to. I actually have a national local bet which has been running.
I don't actually know. I don't know where the betting slip is.
I'm going to have to find it one of these days, which is the,
I put a bet that they would find life on Mars years and years and years ago.
And it was quite an interesting process actually. Cause I,
I went to the bookmakers and they obviously, they couldn't do anything there.
And then, but then they, they, they have specialists, right?
And they put you in touch with their specialists.
And I had a chat with a specialist.
I had assumed that they would like insist there being some time to it, you know,
that you find life on Mars sometime in the next 10 years,
because otherwise it's just a bed that goes on and on forever.
But actually it turns out they don't care cause they get to keep your money
until the bit settled.
So I have this bed that they will find life on Mars and there were various
criteria.
Like it had to be non microscopic and those kinds of things that bacteria
wouldn't count and those kinds of stuff. Um, so.
What were you thinking? You weren't thinking little green men.
I reckon. Well, I, I, I didn't know what I was thinking. Really.
I just thought it was a fun thing to find out whether you could put a bet on
finding life on Mars or not rather than actually thinking they'd find anything.
Um, and I think I'm trying to remember the exact terms.
It didn't actually have to be alive so they could find like fossil remains.
So as long as it wasn't like microscopic that then uh, then it would,
I would win the bet, but I have to find the betting slip one of these days.
Do you think you're going to lose that bail or do you still think you might win?
That is a winning.
And there's still a chance. All right. In here it's still a little,
maybe it'll pay off.
No know Mars was a much nicer.
Place a long time ago and you know, there was water around,
there was an atmosphere. And so you who knows maybe there was like.
When Beetlejuice does go, yes. Do we know any, is there anything,
will we get any clues that it's about to go? We will get a little bit warmer.
I was intrigued by this,
in that I heard various stories about whether we get any advance warning or not.
And the answer is we will.
And so I found a paper that was published a couple of years ago,
neutrinos from Bita processes in a pre supernova,
probing the isotopic evolution of a massive star.
They do a calculation of what the last few hours of a
Star's life is like just before it goes supernova.
I remember the way a star is powered is it burns the various, uh,
chemical elements from one to the next. So by nuclear fusion,
it will turn hydrogen into helium and then helium into carbon and so on up
creating heavier and heavier elements. And the problem with doing that,
if you're a star, is that each time you get less and less bang for your buck,
you know, each the, the hydrogen to helium processes,
you get quite a lot of energy out helium to carbon, a bit less.
And so on in each time you get less and less energy out,
which means that in order for the star to kind of hold itself up,
it has to burn things at an ever more frantic rate in order to do so.
So the last stages of burning are really very intense, but not very energetic.
They don't actually produce much energy and they don't last very long because it
uses up the fuel very, very quickly.
And so this is looking at those last few stages and asking, you know,
what all the processes, and actually more importantly,
is there anything we could detect that would tell us that those processes were
going on and in particular,
the thing that will get straight out from the star or the neutrinos.
So one of the byproducts of lots of nuclear reactions is that you produce these
pathetic little particles called neutrinos.
Basically whenever you turn a neutron into a proton or a proton into a neutron
in some process, um,
you tend to produce one of these neutrinos and neutrinos are such wimpy little
particles that they'll actually travel straight through the star. Um,
and so they don't really care. There's a whole body of a star around it.
So any neutrinos that are produced will stream straight out and what these guys
did is they did some calculations as to say,
how many of these neutrinos are there. And in those last few frantic hours,
when you're burning all these things, as quickly as you possibly can,
it turns out the processes are so intense. You make a lot of neutrinos.
So start spends all that time,
burning fuel and over millions of years.
But the final fuel event is something measured over hours.
Three hours. So we did,
and it really is that frantic that is desperately trying to stay alive.
And so it's using up all the fuel that possibly can.
Sad almost. It's pretty pathetic. Really? It's like it's drowning.
Yeah, no, it really is this frantic. Oh my God, I want God.
I've got to keep going. It just keeps burning all these things. And eventually,
you know, it just runs out or things to burn. So they do these calculations,
they figure out how many neutrinos get produced. And so here they are,
this is the number of neutrinos is being produced per second. And so the,
they did a couple of calculations, 15 solar masses and 30 solar masses.
Beetle juice is around probably around 10, but this,
so this is reasonably close to the kind of thing that will be going on and
beetle juice. And you can see,
this is the luminosity in the number of these things being produced per second.
And you can see as it's coming up towards the end here,
the curves all going up and up and up and up,
but this is one hour before the thing goes,
we're looking at 10 to the 52 neutrinos being produced for second.
So it's a huge number of neutrinos. Then of course,
they split out through space. So by the time they get to the earth,
so many fewer of them,
and then you need a neutrino detector and that's a hard thing to do because
neutrinos just pass straight through everything. And so stopping neutrinos,
detecting neutrinos is a hard thing to do,
but we have some neutrino detectors on earth and they're mostly designed to do
things like detect neutrinos from the sun,
but it turns out that we might actually hope to detect some of these using the
earth bound neutrino detectors.
So they go through that bit of the calculation as well to figure out what you'd
actually expect to see. So they looked at various neutrino detectors,
June and Juno don't actually exist yet.
So the ones that are being built at the moment,
super Kamiyah Conda is one that does exist now.
And they add up all the neutrinos you'd expect to detect.
And they reckon you'd detect slightly less than half a neutrino,
which doesn't sound too promising until you realize that this calculation was
done,
assuming a star that was about five times further away than beetle
uses. And so the number of new, so the neutrino is spread out through space.
They kind of fill the whole area,
which means that the number of neutrinos you would detect,
decreases as one over the distance squared. So if the thing's five times closer,
that means you see 25 times as many neutrinos.
So are half a neutrino turns into about 12 neutrinos.
That doesn't sound very many,
but remember that the only previous time we've detected neutrinos from a
supernova was when the supernova went off in 1987 in the large Medtronic cloud.
And there, they got very excited because they detected 10 neutrinos.
So this is kind of in the ballpark that people are used to detecting from
neutrinos and getting excited about when they detect them. Um,
so actually it will sort of set off the neutrino alarms when it happens and they
will actually have this advance notice. They even,
I think have some directional information.
So I'll even know that these are neutrinos that came from the general direction
of beetle juice.
Is there a system in place for the detector to tell all the telescopes to swing
around and point at Beetlejuice?
I'm not sure there is. Um,
and actually I'm not sure they can process the data that quickly, whether the,
whether it would only, you only find out after the fact,
which is what happened with supernova in 1987 80,
they actually only found out afterwards that actually yes,
we did detect it in neutrinos.
The good news is if it hangs on for a few more years,
these other neutrino detectors come online and you can see that actually were
super coming to condos. Only detecting half a neutrino.
The Juno detector will detect 17. So, and again,
remember that will go up by a factor of 25 just because it's closer than that.
So if we wait around until Juno's online,
then we'll detect lots and lots of neutrinos.
And that really would be a big burst that would be set off some alarms.
You talk about advanced notice,
but that's not because anything bad will happen if Beetlejuice blows up.
Not to us. No, we're far enough away that actually all you'll see is a nice,
big, bright light in the sky. Um, but it's not the, you know,
the gamma rays or anything like that. I'm going to kill us from, uh,
beetle juice when it goes, huh.
This is a long way away. Isn't it? So this is like all stuff in the past.
Yes, it's a 700 light years away. So yeah, it could have gone by now.
And we might have to wait around for a few hundred years for the event to get to
us.
The neutrinos, travel to earth at the same speed as light. So like,
it's not like the explosion will overtake the neutrinos.
And in fact, because,
and because there'll be neutrinos created in the explosion itself and again,
a really, really big number of neutrinos.
So actually this is the sort of pre supernova stuff.
But when the explosion really goes, there'll be a huge burden neutrinos.
And actually they will get to us before we see the light because the neutrinos
come streaming straight out,
but you've got to have this explosive shockwave has got to work its way through
this, uh, the body of the star before we actually see the,
the light of the supernova. So in fact, when the supernova goes,
we'll get a little bit more warning,
but the neutrinos will arrive before the explosion does.
The earth is safe. Is that, let me something that far away,
it's not like we're going,
like there's going to be any warmth heading towards earth.
It's going to cook us though.
As I say, all we'll see is it will be a dramatically bright light in the sky,
but nothing's going to fry how dramatic.
Where you see it in the daytime and it'll.
Be visible in daytime. It'll be about the same brightness as the moon,
so visible in during the day, um, for,
and I think you'll see it during the day for a matter of weeks or months,
and it will be visible to the naked eye for a year or so.
Awesome.
Has there ever been a supernova in our galaxy that we've observed?
Yeah.
Not in recent times. I mean, there were there's so the Chinese records has,
uh, records of supernovae ran with a thousand years ago.
So there have been supernovae in them in the Milky way. Nebula was one of those.
Exactly. The crab memory was one. The only one that sort of in,
in recent times was supernova 1987,
which was in the large managed Niantic cloud in our near neighbor rather than
actually being in our galaxy.
Okay. Uh, I'd love to see one would be pretty cool.
You should call the bookmaker and find out what odds they'll.
On. Beetle juice going. Yeah,
probably not very good at the moment because there's been so much noise about
it. So you didn't see the picture.
So here's a picture. This is what Beatles is.
Just to give you a sense of what a super giant star actually looks like.
This is a picture of beetle juice.
It's sufficiently big that with the very high resolution, uh, uh,
telescopes that we have, like the Atacama large millimeter array,
where we can see the squeezy detail,
we can actually make a picture of the disk of the star itself.
And that's partly because this telescope can make incredibly high resolution
sharp images,
but it's partly because the thing's enormous in that somebody's drawn on here.
What the orbits of the planets in the solar system would be.
And you can see that actually it's bigger than the orbit of Jupiter.
It's a truly enormous object.
The other thing you can see about it is it is a complete mess, right?
That actually is not a nice, uh, uniforms, fear.
There's a bright patch over here.
There's indications that it's not even exactly round that's because it is this
very sort of churning convective system.
It has huge convective cells as things, rising things, falling, things,
being spat out. That actually it's a very, uh, non relaxed system.
And that I think is probably what lies behind the current fading.
That there's one of these phenomenons going on. That's just,
maybe it spat out a load of dust or something that,
which is currently obscuring it.
So we're all we're currently seeing is just one of these processes that's going
on in the outer layers of the star, um, which just,
just made it fight in this rather dramatic way.
The stars, this big have planetary systems, as I understand them, like, do they.
Well, if this wasn't, I mean, it might've had remembered,
this is in a super giant phase before that it was a, you know,
a regular sized star. So if it had a solar system like the earth,
it would have been eaten up by now.
So somewhere inside beetle juice might be like the remains of civilizations.
Well.
Fried at this point, I suspect. Yes.